[Music]
jackson's in denver
hi jackson how are you i'm doing well
dude how about yourself
better than i deserve what's up
uh yeah so i had a question um so a
little background enough
i'm a first generation or was a
first-generation college student um and
i've now found myself living
somewhat of a cliche rich class poor
lifestyle
um recently moved out of the bay area
now here in colorado
and unfortunate enough to you know land
a pretty sought-after job in finance
um you know and about four months ago i
recently purchased a car
and my question to you is you know i'm
paying about 2 300
in rent at the moment and uh you know i
realized i bit off way more than i could
chew
um considering my current income and you
know i have like you know
i've accrued about seven thousand
dollars in credit card debt
um so you know i want to know if i'm
making the right
decision and downsizing and moving out
of the
downtown area that i currently reside in
um
and you know picking up a smaller place
uh currently ending keeping the car and
currently
making payments on and just you know
once kobe da
once covet uh kind of you know gets out
of the picture i commute to work
okay and so what do you owe on the car
um i currently own about 21 000 left in
the car and what is your income
um so my my base about 65 and then my
bonus
is about 55 000 to 60.
okay and you have seven thousand dollars
in credit card debt
right how much student loan debt i'm
sure i
had eight internships and i had two jobs
for college that's paying off
okay you're not afraid of work that's
good okay
and um yeah 2300 is ridiculous in your
situation you do need to move down and
rent
because the rent money that you're
paying is forcing your hand on other
stuff and it's what's caused the credit
card debt
you didn't pay the rent with a credit
card but you gave all your money away to
rent and so you didn't have any money
when you went to buy something
and you used a credit card because your
house poor
exactly it's eating it's eating your
lunch and so i want you on the cheapest
possible thing
and then cut up the credit cards as soon
as you get off the phone
and and it will do that and attack
those cards and let's get let's get
let's get let's get moved
and let's get on a tight budget and uh
you working 40 hours
i'm working about 120 hours currently
wow
but no ot huh uh yeah no it's salary
based it's uh
it's a job and not private equity yeah
okay well jackson i'll tell you this
buddy i i love the idea that you already
have the mindset of downsizing
that shows you willing to sacrifice but
here's the thing that i would be
concerned about
even if you downsize and you continue
the habits you're doing
you're gonna continue to have credit
card debt you're going to continue to
have a car payment so
not only should you downsize but you
need a shift
in your in your mindset and just how
you're looking at money
it's got to be about cash buddy your
income is going to continue to go based
on your age you're making a heck of an
income and it's going to get bigger
what you've got to do is make sure that
you say if i don't have cash i'm not
doing it
right i just i'm not and so i want you
to go to zero and attack that credit
card debt then the car
and you say i'm not going backwards
anymore i mean think about what it feels
like to have absolutely no payments
right now and be living in a cheap place
and saving for your first house
yeah that that's really only about a
year away for you
if you completely start focusing on this
debt because he's got a serious work
ethic i mean that that boy's going
places yeah you're gonna you're gonna be
just fine sir you're doing really well